[Music]
wardell was one of csgo's most
overlooked players
[Music]
the chance
exiled from cs go wardell kept grinding
until he finally found stardom in a new
game
using those smokes just trying to
tailwind
are you [ __ ] kidding me
wardell is one of the biggest names in
valor the man is one of the game's
greatest players
he's a star player on arguably na's best
valorent team and he's just
waiting for his chance to take on the
world but before wardell was soaking up
the limelight in valorant
he was struggling to find a team in cs
go
wardell started competing in cs go in
2014 while he was still
in high school but he didn't really get
noticed until 2016 when he joined
b's money crew they're gonna go quickly
again now
slowing it down a little bit but there's
wardell
somebody stop this guy he's just gonna
beat another one give him three
through the fire why not that's four
let's make it an eight
i'm burning i don't give it come on
wardell
warnell took the next step in his pro
career when the bmc lineup got picked up
by ghost
gaming and while on that team wardell
made a name for himself as an
up-and-coming star in the world of nacs
yeah ghost has looked really impressive
in recent months uh especially in like
esl pro league i think they finished
second at the end of the regular season
which at the beginning of the season i
don't think anyone would have predicted
something about this team is just
clicking and i think one of the biggest
pieces has been wardell his consistency
has finally hit its peak
wardell played alongside some of the
most famous names in north american cs
go
guys like freakazoid kusta and most
importantly
steel now still trying to play around
the edge of the smoke he goes also going
to be there but still is going to come
out on top just once
now this you're going to get me drop
steel how has he stayed alive for so
long
he might be able to turn this back
around for the cts he needs to reload
eventually
he's going to drop a little bit of extra
utility just to keep the teas
at bay and away vice has to rely on the
side arm steel
how has he done this steel just comes
out from that position
and just mops the floor clean see
steel participated in the infamous 2015
match fixing scandal
which meant that he was banned from all
valve tournaments so while he was on the
team
wardell and ghost couldn't actually
qualify for the majors
but even with steel's ban ghost managed
to remain somewhat competitive in cs go
that is until 2019 when goats stepped
away from cs go
and disbanded their roster as ghost's
most promising player
wardell was expected to join another na
team like
cloud9 but no team picked wardell up
and for months he sat in a limbo
unsigned
see wardell's reputation in the nacs
community wasn't that great
about where dell oh just that uh he had
found out that or he decided he was
gonna play for ghost
after practicing with rogue for like two
weeks and then
or a week or something and then uh he
found out last night but he didn't say
anything until two hours before the
match today to one person
in a sour relationship with some of his
fellow nacs go pros
came to bite him in the ass here i was
basically like
black bald from delicious proteins
basically nobody would pick me up
because
it asked like my teammates how like they
feel about me and then like
they completely like lie about who i am
as a like teammate as a person or
whatever
that was definitely a prime factor
because nobody would want to pick me up
and also like not being picked up by an
org is definitely also a factor because
like
due to like covens and all that ain't
nobody trying to pick up a team
so as long as no org was interested in
picking him up wardell decided to make
his own team
orglis and joined up with his fellow
ghost gaming player subrosa as well as
yay
infinite and fns and despite having no
org or sponsors or really even any fans
they managed to qualify for the million
dollar flashpoint league there's a molly
on bentley if you can find an angle for
dark spot but
there's nobody in dark spot there's
nobody there it doesn't help yay now of
course
to maybe get a last kill on to steal and
there it is
a team with no org make it to flash
point one through the pinnacle open
finals
through nothing but hard work wardell
made it back to competitive cs
taking on the same teams that people
thought he was supposed to join months
ago
it's a pretty big moment if wadell goes
down termitiem
there's problems but looks like he'll
get the first kill he might even swing
for the second yes he will
he's gonna nail it but flashpoint came
and went
and wardell didn't get picked up by any
organization
and without the backing of a major team
his career prospects in cs go
were dwindling but in the midst of all
this hardship
wardell got a new opportunity
yeah that's all donna
so like i knew like playing this game in
beta and then getting really good at
before anybody else before this game
blows up would have been the best
opportunity for me then just rather stay
in cs and just like
wait for something magical to happen and
when valorance beta came out
riddell was ready to make a splash
before
you smoke it off yeah oh [ __ ] they're
exactly
just a few weeks into the beta wardell
found his new team
mouse spazz was filled with former
competitive cs go players and they were
ready to take tournaments by storm
uh i think it's because we all had csgo
experience like this game
requires a lot of cs go experience and
then if you don't have cs go experience
you're already behind everybody else
we all played pro before so it's like
super easy to mesh
and like create strats and like bounce
off each other and it's the end of the
line for nerfed in this round
it is him against the world but the
world will crush him down
foggs 13-9 makes mouse bazz
your power and champions and mouse
buzz's success
caught the eyes of one of north
america's biggest esports teams
team solomid i was really happy i was
like wow i've like finally
made my goal for all these years you
know doing it for six years wanting to
join a team
like way before that it's definitely
amazing
honestly after years of grinding his ass
off playing tier 2 cs
wardell was finally on a major
organization
and he was ready to go on a rampage
[Music]
one more one enemy
wow
quickly gained praise for his ability to
completely take over rounds
especially when he got his hands on the
off
i [ __ ] do this give me the [ __ ]
ace give me the [ __ ] ace
give me that [ __ ] ace but despite all
of their success wardell and tsm
couldn't quite say they were the best
team in na
see before they could call themselves
that they had one more opponent to beat
t1
[Music]
relief my friend gg 1310
what a final that was t-one
will come out on top and secure the win
wow what a game what a battle
i was like super sad for a couple days
because i
yeah i like blamed myself the entire
time because there was a lot of rounds
where i could have won it for us
t1's valerent roster was made up of
former competitive cs go players
including three of the five members of
the legendary eye by power roster
brax skadoodle and ack and after t1 beat
tsm in the twitch rival's valorant
tournament
tsm was out for revenge and tsm got
their chance for vengeance just a few
weeks later
at the t1 ballerin invitational the
tournament was part of riot's ignition
series a
set of tournaments meant to kickstart
valerian's esports scene
as part of the ignition series the t1
invitational offered the biggest prize
pool out there for ballard
50 000 which meant that every major team
would be in attendance
and tsm would be ready to play
smoke is played right in front wardell
and wisely enough they actually are just
going to drop that molotov so wardell
hanging out outside
you can get any kind of angle but
there's so much smoke going on there but
wardell still
gets a kill through the plethora of
smokes and then it is
just drone with three to wrap up that
round
wardell's gonna get the intel finds one
maybe a second one two goodbye
and that is gonna be the way you close
that
bad boy out this is the option and now
at this point
you're just gonna try to look for some
exits because you're fully blinded
come out sorry full wine coming through
as well he picks up the phantom in the
first headshot on to azkaban
actually he's going to commit it to this
putting his spoken in front of the site
there
you still have a dark cloud moving in
his dark cover inside the main site
somehow that should have connected he
does connect finally with the ghost
tapping on the spike he does get the
kill too
does he have enough time for the fuse
once again
and he will oh what a clutch remember
goodness as expected tsm and t1 met in
the grand finals
if tsm won this they could truly call
themselves the best team
in na so basically there was like super
a lot of hype around their name and all
that stuff people would like coming to
my chat while i'm streaming be like yo
tm's gonna beat you all that stuff and
like you don't have a chance
onto food and wardell's still lingering
outside
nails another shot on the bracket [ __ ]
that's done it ain't gonna
matter tsm or the first north american
ignition series
champion tsm
is the best valor team on the planet i'm
just going to crown them right now they
call wow
uh when we played them and we we
destroyed them it was the best feeling
ever like and i felt so
like accomplished in my life like i
proved everybody wrong and i proved to
myself that we could be the best in the
world
right now tsm are the kings of n a
valorant
in mid august they won faze clan's 50
000 invitational
and the mvp of that tournament was none
other than the op god himself
wardell oh no
oh no the orbital strike forced them
back
okay so now more delay
but they'll be back in here they can
heal they will be fine but it's a 2v3
now it's going to be a 1v1 it's just up
to sick he's been spectacular but it's
not gonna matter
because wardell gets the final shot and
t s m are your phase
valorent invitational champions
wardell has made it he was overlooked
for years but
instead of giving in he persevered he
kept on grinding
until his chance for glory finally
arrived
well i always look back on it and be
like wow this is actually insane i gotta
like keep on going
it makes me really happy like actually
fulfill my dreams of doing this
and like hitting both like both
streaming and playing pro is definitely
something i wanted to do
my eyes really [ __ ] hurt it is
unbelievable
you know they tell you to not look
directly into lights it's like you get a
little bit of it and then your eyes are
kind of like dazzled for a bit but you
stare at this thing for like 30 minutes
and oh my god
like how long have i been filming for
it's only been like 10 minutes 9 minutes
and 34 seconds is what that says and my
eyes are [ __ ] killing me i can't look
at anything
i'm like actually blind i'm gonna need
glasses by the end of work from home